You are listening to Russell brand on
under the skin with me today is my
guest,
Mr Vice President Al Gore.
Thank you for coming or thank you for
having me.
It must be straight.
There's a what's your film and I loved
your film.
Whenever you come into a room,
everyone stands up.
Is that standard even like you get
standing ovations before joke's been
delivered?
Well sometimes,
sometimes it seems to be the case in the
film.
Now I just do establish it so that you
don't feel obligated and tense about the
promotional aspect of what this
interview must contain.
I think it is important for people to
see this film an inconvenient sequel
speaking truth to power because for me
it rendered the issues of our global
ecology in a way that was easy to
understand.
Made it clear that there is an
imperative that we act now,
but also there's great cause to optimism
that there are shifts both from right
wing thinking.
People like your man at the end near
that sort of our lovely mayor who
shifted in Georgetown,
which is I think sort of like the
bullseye of what you would call
conventional republicanism and also the,
the politics can be functional and
effective.
That's what I got from the,
your activity at the Paris climate
conference where you're able to put
together that deal with a solar energy
company in India who may have reneged on
a,
on a,
on a sort of,
on the Paris climate agreement,
little Doobie.
No.
Then it will be the United States there
would renege on that deal anyway.
So like I think it's an important film
for people to see.
One of the things that struck me,
uh,
Mr Vice President was the way that you
appear to be guided to some degree by
your spirituality,
by your faith.
Much of it was like words like mission
that you see as a personal mission and
uh,
also that some of the language is
somewhat biblical,
unavoidably because of the scale of the
ecological disaster we are facing.
How do,
how does your spiritual perspective
inform your mission to affect global
ecology?
And our attitude towards it.
Well,
first of all,
thank you so much for doing this
interview and for putting so much
thought into it,
Russell.
Um,
I don't wear my spirituality or religion
on my sleeve,
but it is a core part of who I am and
this is a,
an issue of biblical scale in the sense
that the future of humanity could be at
risk where we not to grab hold of this
crisis and solve it.
The good news is that we are beginning
to do just that,
but,
but there is so much at stake you,
it's really essential to put it in the
context of will we have a future or not?
Again,
I'm convinced we will,
but uh,
this is not the normal issue.
We're now seven and a half billion
people.
Our technologies are incredibly powerful
and we have to wrestle with our
vulnerability to short term thinking and
greed and behaviors that don't really
move us forward into the
future,
which are indeed spiritual
issues.
Greed is a spiritual issue.
One of the things I was struck with time
and time again because greed is to
prioritize personal need over social
need or fraternity,
the Brotherhood of man,
the collective is a spirit.
These a spiritual issue because
individualism,
I was clocking Betsey's face in the
background.
I'm always scanning rooms is why I live
on Mr.
Vice President.
I liked saying Mr Vice President,
by the way,
it's an enjoyable thing for person to
say.
Often I have professors and doctors in
here and yeah,
I'm touching a little licks,
social climbing lik spill.
I get to use the term like they,
it feels my own sense of grandiosity
now,
right?
If we live in a world where a conceptual
and a fictitious idea such as economy,
he's prioritized over an actual factual
and material ideas such as ecology.
What hope do we have?
How?
How can we change people's conception,
conception of ecology when we have a a
generation of people,
there've been schooled in consumerist
capitalists thinking,
how are we going to unpick that inner
generation?
Do you think the economic arguments such
as solar panels are cheaper,
will be a sufficient tool to unpick
generations of indoctrination?
People they've been taught to think like
capitalists.
Well,
I think that the,
the rapidly declining cost of both solar
and wind and now electric cars and now
batteries and sustainable agriculture,
forestry,
fisheries,
these new techniques will help us,
but I think you're right that the
emphasis on mass consumption as a
pathway to happiness is definitely a
part of the issue.
You and I probably disagree on the role
of capitalism per se,
and I don't want to get sidetracked too
much into that.
I want to think it is a sidetrack
because how is it that people can ever
think of the world as their home in the
way that you generally do with your
affectionate rather beautiful attachment
to that image of the earth,
that first photograph,
when people clearly see the earth as a
resource culturally,
economically,
and I think on a deep philosophical
level,
if people see the outside world is
something that can be consumed,
relationships that consumed commodities,
they're consumed ideas,
media,
they're consumed without a fundamental
insignificant shift.
How can you hope to achieve such an
ambitious and goal?
Thanks mate.
As saving the world.
Yeah.
Well I do totally agree with you.
Uh,
the,
uh,
we need a shift in consciousness and we
need,
uh,
a a keen awareness of what we're doing
to the earth.
Uh,
and,
but,
but I do want to tell you about my views
where capitalism is concerned.
I believe that the alternatives to
capitalism in some form or explored in
the 20th century,
both on the left and the right and they
were found to have some,
some serious problems and excesses.
But capitalism in its current form I
think is in need of serious reform.
We need to start putting a price on the
so called externalities like pollution,
also the positive externalities.
A,
we count investments in education and
mental health care and treatment for
addictions and community services as as
an expense.
And then we ignore the benefits of those
expenditures.
So that's a distortion that needs to be
remedied.
We don't account for the depletion of
natural resources and we should,
we ignore the growing inequality in
incomes,
which is threatening the future of
democracy.
If we don't
up.
Yes,
because built into the economic model
under which we labor,
there is no potentiality for the
inclusion of crisis right now.
The failings of the ideologies of the
last century and all their extremism and
the war and the have a good they rigged
for me,
does not put a full stop on the
potential for new systems and evolve in
systems and merge in national socialism.
Terrible,
terrible idea.
Communism as practice,
particularly Soviet communism,
which really repeated the model of the
czar ism that proceeded it rather than
being a legitimate,
you know,
Soviet experience where power wasn't
paralleled and equalized.
I,
you know,
clearly a huge failure,
but that doesn't mean that it doesn't
need to be huge shifts.
I'm thinking of,
I've heard this quote and I want you to
think about it.
It's by this man called a Sateesh Calla
east.
When he spoke to Bertrand Russell,
who obviously in the late sixties was a
prominent campaign for nuclear
disarmament and he said,
what's the point in getting rid of these
nuclear missiles if we don't change the
consciousness that invented them?
Because people will continue to manifest
these kinds of tools and these kinds of
weapons.
Something about that stays with me,
that what you seem to have experienced
personally is a transformation in the
way that you see the world now.
How much impact can be had politicking
at the Paris climate to get India to
accept solar power only for the u s to
renege on it because of individualism,
consumerism,
materialism.
A platform that's been laid for 50 years
for Donald Trump.
Donald Trump didn't appear in a vacuum,
although there seems to be one inside of
him and it like,
so like,
you know,
so I think that,
how do I think we have to be to a key to
the kind of thing that you want to
achieve?
I think that there needs to be a
transformation on an individual level
that is quite,
quite profound.
Yeah,
I think that's true.
I think that there are fundamental
truths about human nature that are going
to cause both problems and
opportunities.
Whatever political or economic system we
find ourselves living in.
I have always had immense respect for
those,
uh,
for the founders of the United States of
America because they were humanists who
separated religion from politics and
actually took into account some of these
truths about human nature.
And I'm a British citizen.
Lord acton said famously,
power corrupts absolute power corrupts
absolutely.
And putting boundaries around the
accumulation of too much power by a
single individual or a small group of
individuals either in the political
system or the economic system is a
recipe for danger.
And one of the problems we have this,
one of the reasons we have this climate
crisis is that the large carbon
polluters have accumulated too much
power to influence our politics.
And they distorted the conversation
about climate by using their money to
put out climate denial and create false
stouts in exactly the same way that the
tobacco companies did years ago.
They hired actors and dressed them up as
doctors and put them in front of cameras
to falsely reassure people that what the
doctors had found out about smoking
cigarettes and lung cancer was not true.
And now the carbon polluters are doing
exactly the same thing about the climate
except with a half a century of
entrenched and funding for academic
studies.
So now they don't require actors because
the whole thing is theater.
The whole thing is a play.
And when you talk about the potency of a
utility monopolies,
uh,
Mr Vice President Al Gore long name to
say continually,
Oh you can accuse al just now.
It's actually happened.
Your adequacy if you want to be proper,
your adequacy for is that,
that's a formal okay.
Instead of your activist.
Sweet hell is fine.
Cause I for a minute,
for a minute,
you were laughing at their rigmaroles of
English culture,
Your Highness.
Uh,
I mean we have a title over here by God.
Um,
so yeah,
like for a person that's been vice
president,
the United States in a period in which
many of the economic decisions that have
led to the kind of entrenched monopoly
utility monopolies that we are on the
Asian American now there's this suffers
is a pap test or you're a fair word to
you.
You know,
you were there.
Yeah.
So I've heard it said before that a lot
of people said,
oh,
I left parliamentary left Congress so I
could focus on politics.
You know,
because you know,
Yanis Varoufakis came in here once and
he said politicians only have power
within the limitations of their role.
Did you find that when you were vice
president,
the United States that your power was
quite limited?
That the,
our ability to be effective,
particularly with their issues that
you're passionate about?
Like ecology,
we're limited because ultimately stay
power is nullified by superseding
economic powers and financial interests.
Well,
I think,
uh,
the skillful exercise of political
power,
which includes the mobilizing of public
opinion,
can bring about to more potential for
change then perhaps in any other
position.
But one of the limitations of working in
the White House is that you cannot focus
only on one issue.
You have the responsibility to focus on,
on many.
And one of the luxuries that I have now
is the,
the freedom to focus almost exclusively
on the climate crisis and elements of
the crises that are connected to the way
our news media operates,
the way our economic system operates.
But I see it almost exclusively now
through the lens of the climate crisis
say and,
and I think we,
we have to make it the top priority.
I agree with you,
but is that sort of a moot point?
Unless there is sort of powerful
legislation on an international level
that pre prevent or prohibits
profiteering by these monopoly utilities
that you speak wouldn't affects,
let the call crises of our planet and
say well the way the oil is refined,
the amount of profit these companies
here,
like you said,
they're more heavily saturated.
Like traditional energy resources are
more heavily subsidized and modern
renewable energy times as what do we
make that legal overnight?
Just like stop,
stop subsidizing.
It may go,
I,
it doesn't even require a kind of
radicalism.
Cause when I see these apocalyptic
river,
Lake Erie in the GS fires,
storms,
Filipino death,
then I think,
well it's not too much to ask to simply
say right from the,
forget 24 or 2050 or so.
I'm a far flung title of a Kubrickian
movie tomorrow.
No more profit in.
But these are not now.
That's not possible.
Is it?
Because the political and economic
model,
which is in a way tissues is conjured by
the consciousness of man will not permit
it.
You can't make those kinds of change.
You can't say,
well there's no more GM anymore.
There's no Exxon Exxon's close reclaims
it.
There was a famous economist who wants
a,
uh,
things take longer to happen than you
think they will.
And then they happen much faster than
you thought they could.
And changes in consciousness sometimes
take time,
but they can occur.
And this climate movement is very much
in the tradition of previous movements
that changed consciousness.
The abolition of slavery,
the granting of the right to vote to
women,
the civil rights movement.
And in my country anti apartheid,
most recently the gay rights movement,
if someone had told me even five years
ago that gay marriage would be legal in
all 50 us states and would be accepted,
honored and celebrated by two thirds of
the American people,
I would have said,
I sure hope so,
but I think you're being completely
unrealistic.
But the climate movement,
like all these previous movements
eventually gets to the point where the
straw man or discarded and you see the
central question,
which is a choice between what is moral
and right and what is immoral and wrong.
And that's where we are right at that
tipping point in the climate movement.
Now
I hear you well,
but prominent civil rights campaign.
And one said to me like power will
always yield on civil rights issues
eventually because ultimately it doesn't
affect their,
their,
their resources.
But when you go for money,
that's when you will face resistance now
and,
and it to be,
um,
Penika eight while I was there have been
a huge success.
He's in civil rights in the last half
century.
One don't have to spend too long on
google to see that.
Right now we're talking about something
where there is a huge ticking clock,
so I don't,
I suppose it's not like I want to
encourage his steria,
but I sort of sense that radicalism is
required and you in your new
transcendent role to a role as a kind of
global mench a bodhisattva of the
climate movement.
Oh,
sort of uniquely positioned to spell
out,
just like pauses the film.
I watched it.
I think,
my God,
this is a serious,
serious crisis and you're educating
people all over the world.
You're doing a tremendous job.
Who am I?
I Amia celebrity to even question you on
this subject,
but my point is,
is this a type of a,
seems to me.
My intuition is so the recession and
trenching corruption within politics,
the,
the financial industry has these things
sewn up so deeply.
The ordinary people find this so hard to
have purchased that in each of the
issues that you have said,
whether it's women's rights,
African American rights,
civil rights are partners,
but blood is spilled.
Great men are imprisoned,
women die in chains before anything
changes.
Do we have this time with this
apocalyptic issue?
Do we not have to evoke the day it is in
the demons?
Do we not have to speak to level people
on the level of their deepest,
truest self about what kind of world
they want to live in,
what they're prepared to sacrifice,
who they are prepared to confront and
when,
no,
I don't disagree with that at all.
I think it is time for people to take
action.
Absolutely.
And to uh,
I'm very proud my daughter was arrested
in a protest against the new natural gas
pipeline network.
So you know,
times have changed when a parent says,
oh I'm so proud of my daughter was
arrested.
I am.
What does that say about authority when
a parent is now proud that authority,
his challenge,
he says all authority is de facto
corrupt toe.
No,
Donald Trump really is it just a
grotesque exagrid exaggeration as the
proceeding decades and no disrespect,
cause you took part in those
administrations,
but without [inaudible] and without a
Bama,
you don't get trump.
We were being coached.
We're being lubricated.
We've been fluffed and prepared for the
trump,
for the trump thrust.
I don't know what to call it,
if phallic references seem somehow
appropriate with that man.
But,
but like,
you know,
we've school,
we told people to be individualists,
we taught people to be materialistic and
consumers.
And now we're surprised when it's a
selfish,
racist,
sexist precedent that leads the world.
Well,
I,
I would interpret that history
differently from the way you do.
I think that there are a lot of good
people trapped in bed systems,
but when you work for positive change,
uh,
sometimes there is a backlash.
And I think that trump represents of
backlash.
I think that brexit represented of
I think that for a lot of complex
reasons,
globalization,
intelligence added to automation of the
growth of inequality.
There is a lot of unhappiness and unrest
about the stagnation of middle income
wages for some decades now.
And the,
and a demagogue can take advantage of
that and focus it in an irresponsible
way.
But the next is of each and every one of
those issues.
Is it an economic system that will not
yield power?
You know,
when we talk about,
oh,
how do we have this system is because
the people that are dominant,
this system works absolutely fine.
Thank you.
We don't want to change it.
We don't care if the planet is
destroyed.
We don't care if there is this,
the,
if there's economic inequality across
the planet,
I would see brexit and trump as if
forgive my language as a democratic
population and saying,
fuck you to power.
In both cases you've not looking after
us.
Why should we care?
We've been taught that those limbs are
different.
We've been taught that women are
inferior.
We've been taught all this.
Talk about gay people.
Shepherd hit.
People are bored of hearing it because
they've said for decade after decade
they've witnessed power,
not com taking care of their interests.
I think that's right.
I think there are,
I think this wave of populaced
authoritarianism is a response to the
unhappiness and anxiety that people have
been feeling for quite some time,
but how do we bring change in spite of
economic interests posing it?
Take one example,
the anti apartheid movement in South
Africa.
You're talking about an economic,
a set of interests of posing that
change.
That was massive.
Nelson Mandela said it's always
impossible until it's done.
Oh and this kind of change comes about
sometimes when the potential for change
bills up,
pushing against a barrier that suddenly
gives away and then you see a tremendous
change that people did think was
impossible but eventually came.
Yes.
I think there's a generational aspect of
change as well.
I think the younger generation now is
far more committed to saving the climate
than those in my generation and I think
it's because they've seen that every
night on the news is like a nature hike
through the book of revelation and if
the news media doesn't connect the dots,
then they connect the dots themselves,
they and their understanding that this
change is essential.
It does require a new way of thinking.
I absolutely agree with that.
How do we bring that about or ranting
and railing against?
It has its place working within,
and I'm not characterizing you that that
way Russell.
I myself have been characterized that
way based on the film you ranting and
railing guys think that has its place,
but patiently working within the system
as it exists to try to,
you pull the levers and press the
buttons and make the machinery operate
in a more constructive way also has its
place.
But Owl,
every one of these examples you give,
I can't help but think of an alternative
narrative.
You know,
Nelson Mandela,
he went down for 27 years.
He was prepared to kill and die for what
he believed in.
And ultimately I've think if we
investigate it though the apartheid
ended when the economic interests that
were the benefit from a pied found a way
of maneuvering so that they couldn't
maintain their power
with our pod.
And having been to South Africa
relatively recently,
I didn't fancy being black.
They're much,
you know what I mean?
I didn't figure this would be a dotted
line moving in and out of town shit,
but there's of people are still living
behind barb wire,
you know.
Now with all the way from my limited
experience,
it seems like what power does is what is
the bare minimum we can give these
people what is the bare minimum?
So if we aim at bare minimum,
that's what they'll give us.
So for me it seems like what we should
do is focus on radical annihilation
overhaul and revolution and that way we
might get some kind of parity,
some kind of justice.
So like,
do you not think like I understand that
rule changes happening.
He know that solar power and renewable
energies is better.
You're right,
you're 100% right.
So like why not focus on identify the
obstacles and then make it clear that
these are the targets.
Like these companies are the problems.
That's what I tried to do.
Attack.
That's exactly what I try to do is to
focus
so on Koch brothers.
Absolutely.
So why,
what,
like why if you'd like a y con we have,
right.
Exxon now has to be nationalized.
It's already subsidized.
We were already paying for it.
So now we're going to own it.
Why can't you do that?
Uh,
you know,
part of the movie focuses on the
investigation of Exxon Mobil that's now
underway.
I hope they will be held legally
accountable for the fact that they have
financed climate denial as the Koch
brothers have financed climate denial.
They,
they've tried to fool people into
thinking like rises isn't real and now
they're trying to fool people into
thinking that the renewable alternatives
are not viable and real as well.
It's very insidious.
Yeah.
Stdz ncds and the consequence of it is,
I suppose maybe a law.
I am,
I see the world differently.
See,
I recently became a father.
I have a nine month old.
Congratulations.
Thank you man.
It's changed everything.
I'm so in love with her is incredible.
What's her name?
Mabel.
I went for a walk over this morning in
the fields near where we live.
I look at the tree,
I look at every time and I think about
that.
Our connection to nature is absolute.
This is it.
Like,
and when you show the images you
repeatedly do in your film an
inconvenient sequel.
Wishing I wasn't,
you know,
music,
good title.
In a way.
It's sort of ironic.
I like it.
It's cool,
but it's got the word convenient cause
Mary at apple now vice vice metta,
um,
like it makes me feel that we,
one has to nurture the inherent
connection we have with this planet.
We have to personalize it.
All things have become commodified is
very difficult for people that are
struggling to see the significance of
broad global issues when globalization,
whilst it is bought sort of a commodity
revolution and we've all got wonderful
phones.
Thank you very much.
They're delightful.
What it's also done is this turned us
into a planet of consumers that C,
and this is why at the beginning of this
interview I spoke about spirituality
because I think this is where the
transformation must take place.
The way we regard the exterior world,
the way that we regard God ourselves and
our role on this planet as you evidently
do as a servant.
You are obviously living in service now
and other feeling that I will let you
know if I dare piece of boulders to
speak for most people.
I think most people think that
politicians are corrupt,
people in positions of power are
untrustworthy and manipulative lawyers
and that we should divorce ourselves
from power and and I think to have a
person in your position who has been
behind the curtain who must know things
that if you uttered them out loud,
your life would be at risk.
To see a person like q embracing an
issue in this way is very,
very heartening for ordinary people.
My hope is that we continue to
aggressively pursue these issues and
identify and target who the problem is
aggressively.
Oh,
I agree.
This is the time for for passion.
This is the time for people to mobilize.
I couldn't agree more.
I wish we had to for longer vice
president Al Gore,
but I know there are many,
many people to speak to a that you've
got a an important and busy schedule.
It's been really,
really lovely to have you here.
I respect you very much once.
I bet you weren't man,
the movie 340 theaters or this Friday
and tickets are available at all of the
places you get them and then a week from
Friday it opens widely all across
England.
Uh,
an inconvenient sequel.
Truth to power guys.
See you'll probably get more from it
then a go a lot.
I watched it.
I was really enjoyed him.
He might feel guilty in popcorn like at
certain points I might think,
oh no,
what am I doing with my life?
But it's an optimistic film.
You will learn from it.
I endorse this film.
I went and saw it.
And normally you know how you have to
infuse,
interview someone important like you,
they force you to watch the film
normally got a guy in any way.
Someone else watch it and tell me this
one.
I actually went and saw myself and I
enjoyed it.
Thank you.
Thank you for saying that.
And I like your relationship with your
dog.
I like your cowboy boots.
I like,
I like a lot of things about you.
Alcohol or thank you for what you're
doing for the world.
Thank you for the interview.